you've launched a small business
learning center for anyone trying to
start a small business
that you're trying to help and you've
launched a 50 million dollar foundation
to help small businesses and families
call the lemonade foundation i might be
missing
uh i mean i i guess you know that's just
a play on your name
at like uh lemonis so
you know it's um the reason i launched
the learning center is that one of the
things that i learned through my
eight-year
journey with over a hundred businesses
on the air
is that there's a common thread of what
they were missing and they were missing
a depth of education
and the education isn't one plus one
equals two or what's the capital of the
state of florida
it's what are the real things that
happen in a business from inventory
management to hr risk to
you know hundreds and hundreds of topics
and you know that as a business owner
that those things happen and so i wanted
to create a center
where people felt hey it's free
b people could do it in the privacy of
their own home and there are so many
folks who don't know the answer to
things but they're embarrassed to admit
they don't know it
um and i i'm one of those people
sometimes if you ask me a question i may
fake it
um and i decided years ago that i wasn't
going to fake it i was going to say
can you explain that to me i don't know
it i don't understand that
and i realize that the key is it's very
powerful if you can acknowledge
ignorance it's very powerful
it's it makes the other person feel uh
i think more connected to you yeah
because you're saying like andrew i
don't understand how that works
and uh it really hit me one day i got a
call from jamie dimon
uh uh from you know from jp morgan i was
uh working on something my phone rang
uh on the other end of the line hi uh is
this marcus yes
uh hi this is jamie okay i didn't know
who it was
i'd like to just talk to you for a few
minutes you have a few minutes i'm kind
of in the middle of something um
but i would be glad because i might you
could find my cell phone on the internet
and i said i'd be glad to talk to you i
can't do it right now he said
well um you know i'm your banker and i
said
okay i'm sorry sir i i think you may
have me confused my banker is
i said this woman's name he goes no no
i'm that woman's boss
and he said this is jamie dimon i said
no seriously
who is this like i i'm really busy and
he said well listen i only called i got
mine
i got your phone number uh from steve
burke who is the chairman of nbc at the
time
who was on the board and he said i just
want to call and tell you that
um i know you think you're only helping
small business but you're really helping
people understand
the human psychology of business
and that is something that you can't
teach
in a classroom and uh i just wanted to
tell you that and then they
chase ended up becoming like a six-year
sponsor of the show
nice the point the point of that is i
think for me is
you like what you do and what i do all
we're trying to do is just educate
inform inspire that's it
again you you've acted in a way that's
really
unique singular because you've walked
the walk
for years at great personal cost not
just
in terms of uh financial resources but
really the most precious thing of all
which is like your time
energy and spirit i'm actually going to
to
explain to you what i did which was like
my my shot at the same problem
just because i want to hear what you
think um so
i you and i graduated from college
around the same time i was not as
enterprising as you so i went to law
school
and then after i went to law school i
tried to start a business that did not
work out and then
ended up going through sort of the ups
and downs of entrepreneurship um
and so years later after my company was
acquired
in 2009 and 2011 i started a non-profit
that tried to train the next generation
of entrepreneur
and help startups grow so the
organization's called venture for
america i want to see what you
hear what you think of this um so the
thought process was that they're all of
these
enterprising college graduates who want
to learn to become someone like you
but right now they go to jpmorgan and
deloitte these big consulting and
finance shops to quote-unquote learn
about business
so what venture for america does venture
for america puts them through a boot
camp
of five weeks and then sends them to
work at early stage growth companies run
by entrepreneurs
in detroit cleveland baltimore new
orleans
birmingham and other cities around the
country so it's like a two-year national
entrepreneurship apprenticeship
fellowship and
at the end of two years if they want to
start their own business then we have
investors in a seed fund to put money
into them and so the goal was to try and
create like an army
of future use essentially
by sending them to work at these
organizations
so the way that you have like the
learning center to try and teach people
about these things
though our approach was we had that camp
but then we said look just go work at
the business for two years
at like these formative um 20s
you know because most of them are coming
out of college
wow i mean what an amazing idea and how
long has the program been running
uh we started it in 2011 so it's nine
years in
um we have some real successes where
some of the alums have started
significant enterprises
uh you know at this point i think we're
responsible for something like maybe
like a few thousand jobs like depending
upon how you
calculate it um i should put you in
touch with the the ceo but i i started
and ran that organization full time
uh for six and a half years and it was
only after i
realized that the pro the changes in our
economy were going to be much bigger and
hairier than anything i could counteract
with like my
army of uh entrepreneurs that i decided
to do the
inadvisable thing of running for
president
well you made a statement and i think it
was an appropriate statement to make
i think you gave a lot of people a lot
of hope and and
the idea of possibilities and
opportunity and i think that that
singular uh moment was a huge character
defining moment
the fact that you're giving young
entrepreneurs
a chance to work in the real world and
then
if they succeed and if they follow the
program
there's opportunity for them to do more
is really
i think at the center of what i believe
in which is i want to give you a hand
up but i'm not going to give you a
handout
and you got to work for it and you got
to show me you're committed to it and
the way you show me you're committed to
it
is by going to work and following
through and i think that's amazing
how how can other people get involved in
the organization people like me
oh people like you jeez marcus will roll
out the red carpet i'll put you in touch
with the ceo
uh because you could speak at the
training camp um
you know you could mentor some of the
folks who are coming out uh you know you
could
do you could i mean invest in in some of
the the
growth businesses uh you'd love it it's
essentially an army of
aspiring use and
uh and to me the problem is that like if
you're an aspiring you i mean you and i
both had like
you know frankly like stumbles in our
20s because like you're just trying to
figure it out and like
and it's a very isolating circumference
we had stumbles in our 40s i think
yesterday you stumbled the whole time
it's true
uh you know and and i'm sure in your
case too you you eventually have like a
few
uh people that you connect with on like
a real human level
um that understand you and what drives
you that that's the most beautiful thing
about venture for america marcus is
these young people become so close to
each other
uh that like imagine having that kinship
early on where instead of people just
thinking you're crazy there are at least
a few other crazy people like you
that are like yeah do that there's a
number of organizations
out there that don't do a similar thing
in practice but in terms of principle of
that camaraderie it's like a ypo type
organization
where these young folks are sort of part
of the fraternity of young entrepreneurs
and there's something that
those lifelong relationships can never
be fractured i mean what you've done is
incredible um and i can sense you and i
saw the same
need and then you know we went after it
in different ways uh
like so it's that's one reason why i'm
such an
admirer of yours is like i understand
the spirit uh and and the spirit of what
drives you the spirit of
um of helping people become stronger
versions of themselves through this
process of entrepreneurship in many ways
because like the business of the
business but really it's about the
people
like it it's it's so vital in american
life and we don't talk about it enough
like you're you're one of the primary
champions that exists
of this uh and like
it used to be much more built into
american life uh but
now it's less so um i i think that's one
reason why
andrew why is that i mean there are a
few very very big reasons
uh you know if someone asks me like i i
say a lot of it is that we're in the
midst of the most extreme winner take
all economy in the history of the world
where
when you and i were coming out of
college there was no amazon like now
what's amazon amazon's like a
like one to two trillion dollar company
that you know just like hoover's up
commerce right in the left
like a generation ago if someone were to
want to start a hardware
store you might think that's a good idea
and then eventually you know like the
the big box retailers made that a bad
idea and then i liken it the big box
retailers were like tanks that came to
town
and the mom and pop businesses were like
oh no there's a tank um
and amazon's like a spaceship so if
you're like these
small business owners you look up and
you're like how the hell do i compete
with a spaceship
now you know like the spaceship doesn't
even need to make money in a given
quarter the spaceship has unlimited
capital unlimited data like so
um so so that's one big reason why it's
harder
you know for young people it's that
the college education that you and i
received in the 90s got two and a half
times more pricey
at some point and so you have these
young kids coming out
who now have you know life-changing debt
in a way that
like for you and me back in the 90s it
was plausible that we could quote
unquote work our way through school
you could actually like make enough
money to maybe pay for your school
but that was back when college cost uh
you know 20 to 25 grand a year and not
60 grand a year and like you know it's
like
can a kid like you know uh work their
way through 60 grand a year it's like
less likely
and then their choices get constrained
like a lot of the
community financial institutions that
used to exist got gobbled up by
you know like the jp morgans of the
world where like the the consolidation
you see in retail for amazon has
happened in financial services for sure
it happens in tech for sure like like
there are a lot of like the biggest
industries that have become consolidated
around like a few winners um you know
media and journalism is another like
2000 local newspaper is gone so if
you're like a local journalist like you
know
like that that's gone and so you you
have a shot if you go to new york and
work for
um for nbc or like one of those like you
know
those outlets persist um so there's
something
uh that's been lost and people like you
and i are looking at it and we've sensed
it
and then we're like huh like we and and
what gets lost too
is that process that makes those people
into the people they aspired to be
like in in some ways the people that you
and i have become
uh that we're kind of an earlier
generation than a lot of them
yeah it um i worry about where
we go from here and i
along with you feel like it's time to
double down
on the young people because i don't know
what 10 years
20 years looks like if they become
disenchanted
or disillusioned or suppressed and so
when we started this foundation this 50
million dollar foundation
it was exclusively uh to provide
financial grants loans and
equity investments to underserved
communities and underserved individuals
and people have said incredible
yeah you're just you're just trying to
help poor people
and i said no i'm actually not trying to
help any specific
class of people other than those who
have not been given the same
opportunities that i was given
period and so we don't need to debate it
because it's my money
it kind of doesn't matter what you think
and so
it's not like i'm using your money or
the government's money this is what i
believe in there are women
uh and people of color who haven't been
given the same opportunity
by the way when they take my money i'm
going to put them through the same paces
the same way i just want people to feel
like if they had an opportunity
what would they do with it if they fail
it's no different than people that are
males or people that are not of color
it's so i just i worry about them and i
worry about
our our societal disregard or lack of
acknowledgement
people like to talk about it and say we
should start a fund and you watch a lot
of these big companies well we're we're
donating a certain amount of money to
this cause it's like it's not a cause
it's not a charity these people are not
um
they're not they're not unfortunately
they're not um
you know um uh handicapped they're not
disabled
they're just uh socio and economically
disabled and i wanna try to fix that am
i gonna fix it
i probably won't am i gonna try for damn
sure
you're gonna fix it you're going to fix
it for um
a certain number of people and that in
itself is incredible like if it's just
for one
then exactly thank you for listening in
i hope you enjoyed this conversation if
you did
please do subscribe to yangspeeks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode you